die die ukraine können gerne kommen und
die unterstützung auch gerne egal was es
kostet sie haben sich das ja auch nicht
ausgesucht und wenn wir in der situation
wären dann würden wir das ja genauso
wollen und uns wünschen weil sie hilfe
brauchen und weil ich im krieg geboren
bin und die flüchtlinge erlebt haben
also 45 56 stunden nach dresden kam
jeden dem irgendwie helfen können sollte
man unter die arme greifen nicht nur
aufnehmen auch noch mehr tun
unterstützen auch finanziell oder
emotional ist ja eigentlich auch relativ
wichtig bei solchen kriegssituationen
ich denke da kann man relativ viel
helfen jeder einzelne muss sehen was er
machen kann und kurz richtig einfach
essen unterkunft bis wir hoffentlich
sehr schnell diesen konflikt beenden
können
niemand der ein herz hat lässt kalt was
da geschieht auf das geheiß von putin
ein kriegstreiber wien bundeskanzler
olaf scholz gestern nannte ein präsident
der inzwischen sogar mit atomwaffen
droht und damit herzlich willkommen zu
diesem zdf spezial wir nehmen uns auch
heute 45 minuten um auf die menschen zu
schauen die unter diesem krieg zu leiden
haben aber auch auf jene die
zusammenstehen um damit wohl das
stärkste zeichen auszusenden richtung
kreml wie gestern in berlin
beispielsweise
hunderttausende die für den frieden und
die freiheit der ukraine solidarisch auf
die straße gehen und heute in köln dazu
gleich vereint wie lange nicht zeigt
sich auch europa die flüchtlinge die in
diesen tagen richtung westen kommen
finden offene arme wir beginnen den
polen am grenzort chemische während
ihrer männer im land zum kämpfen bleiben
suchen frauen und kinder den mühsamen
weg raus natalie steger berichtet
noch kommen züge an aus der ukraine am
polnischen grenzbahnhof in chemischen
aus kiew aus odessa lewis die züge in
den frieden tausende sind seit
donnerstag angekommen wie katharina und
ihr sohn geflohen aus level die katze
den hund wir haben alles schnell gepackt
und dann sind wir mit einem kleinen zug
nach polen gefahr
mein älterer bruder ist geblieben er
wird kämpfen die
sicherheit das rote kreuz hilft
medizinisch die welle der
hilfsbereitschaft ist groß in polen
nicht nur vertreter von behörden und
organisationen helfen mit viel empathie
auch viele privatleute auch aus dem
ausland bewegt das schicksal der
flüchtlinge sowie matthias kind er ist
aus hamburg angereist und will menschen
mitnehmen ihnen unterkunft anbieten
ich will nicht dass sie jemand auf dem
fußboden schlafen muss keine mutter mit
kindern deren mann jürgen rupp krieges
vor allem frauen und kinder sind hier
weil die männer zwischen 18 und 60
jahren die ukraine nicht verlassen
dürfen verteidigen sollen auch ihr mann
blieb
er sagte ich werde unser zuhause
schützen du musst gehen weil du die
kinder in sicherheit bringen muss
gestrandet am bahnhof nur mit dem was
sie tragen konnten manche haben
verwandte in polen andere wissen nicht
wohin der mutter und jeder fragen die
helfer wie sie sich einbringen können
wir haben zimmer ein eigenes haus wir
suchen nach einer mutter mit kindern die
wir aufnehmen können
wir sind mit dem nötigsten bekommen wir
hoffen dass das alles aufhört und wir
wieder nach hause gehen können
putin wütet in polens nachbarland sorgen
kommen auf die längst vergessen schien
russland das ewige schreckgespenst
polens
wissen wir denn dass wir nicht auch bald
in dieser situation sind auch fliehen
und hilfe suchen
am wochenende es ist ein grenzübergang
an der autobahn aber die menschen
drängen ihn danach zu fuß aus der
ukraine nach polen raus wie auch immer
endlich ist die beschwerliche reise aus
dem kriegsgebiet geschafft viele frauen
mit kindern fahren auf der autobahn aus
wir kamen zu fuß und das war sehr hart
aber jetzt sind wir hier und es ist okay
viel besser als in der ukraine
auf der polnischen seite wird die
autobahn zum parkplatz angehörige suchen
geflohene freiwillige die transport
anbieten wollen die menschen aufnehmen
aber es gibt kein vor und kein zurück
damit die geflohenen nicht so lange in
der kälte warten müssen werden sie in
bussen zu einem einkaufszentrum pracht
sie haben sogar einen autokindersitz
mitgebrachte nierstein domenica bieten
fahrten nach krakau oder katowice an und
alles was auf dem weg liegt es gibt
unzählige solcher helfer und helferinnen
das ist doch normal dass die leute
helfen und das ist alles das ist keine
große geschichte wir werden einfach
gebraucht und wir müssen es machen
grenzübergang mit dicker wo die menschen
seit anfang der russischen offensive
nach polen kommen oft seit 23 tagen
unterwegs ausgehungert erschöpft essen
sachspenden viele polinnen und polen
helfen auch hier
hier zieht schlechtes wetter auf aber
die menschen die es nach polen geschafft
haben die werden jetzt in busse gebracht
oder privatleute holen sie ab und ihrer
reise hat ein vorläufiges ende und sie
sind in sicherheit aber auf der
ukrainischen seite da müssen die
menschen stundenlang warten bis er es
hierüber nach polen schaffen
und auch auf polnischer seite warten sie
ukrainer und ukrainerinnen sowie tasche
am freitag tag zwei nach der russischen
offensive sie hofft dass mutter und
schwester es bald zu ihr schaffen immer
in kontakt mit ihnen
erwartet sie ruhig ich habe sehr große
angst
weil ich nicht will dass mein land in
solch einer situation ist
krieg in der ukraine es werden wohl
millionen werden die ihr land verlassen
rückkehr ungewiss
ja und 370.000 menschen haben sich
inzwischen aus der ukraine
herausgekämpft schätzen die vereinten
nationen die europäische union richtet
sich bereits auf millionen ein dick
kommen werden und hat gestern abend
dafür gesorgt dass es jetzt schnell
gehen kann die sogenannte massenzustrom
richtlinie aus dem jahr 2001 soll
aktiviert werden das heißt es ist kein
aufwändiges asylverfahren nötig um
schutz zu garantieren
ein schulterschluss aller eu-staaten
sagt innenministerin phaser wie sehr das
not zeigt sich auch an der grenze der
ukraine zur slowakei dort ist auch heute
für uns britta hilpert wie gut läuft die
organisation heute
also ich muss sagen es ist viel
organisierter viel weniger chaotisch als
in den letzten tagen hier sind
verschiedene zelte aufgebaut hier zb
bekommen ukrainer und ukrainerinnen eine
sim karte von einem telefonanbieter
umsonst damit sie kontakt haben können
da drüben steht eine bank bietet
unterkünfte an und jede menge andere
organisationen stehen hier mit ihren
zelten bieten einfach nur auf was zu
essen an was warmes zu trinken denn
gerade auch morgens und abends ganze
empfindlichkeit werden von dort drüben
von der grenze kommen immer noch gruppen
vor allem von frauen und kindern die
kommen immer so schubweise aber wir
hören dass zumindest die fußgänger nicht
mehr so lange warten müssen für autos
dauert es bis zu 48 stunden bis sie hier
über die grenze kommen können so ein
empfang ist das ein aber wie geht es den
menschen die kommen
ja die menschen die hier ankommen sind
immer noch ich muss einen englischen
ausdruck gesellschaft also sie sind
traumatisiert das muss man so sagen ich
habe einige getroffen die tatsächlich
auch aus kriegsgebieten hierher gekommen
sind andere kommen aus gebieten die noch
friedlich sind aber alle stehen
natürlich unter dem schock dass sie nun
plötzlich ihre heimat verlassen müssen
und ihre männer zurücklassen müssen denn
die wehrfähigen männer dürfen ja aus der
ukraine nicht mehr raus sie sollen
kämpfen und so müssen sie hier mit sack
und pack und mit kindern ankommen wissen
oft nicht wohin aber ich habe den
eindruck dass die slowakei sich auf
vieles vorbereitet hat unweit von hier
ist auch eine zeltstadt aufgebaut
mehrere notunterkünfte inland sind
eingerichtet turnheim in schulen werden
vorbereitet also es gibt möglichkeiten
für die die nicht wissen wohin aber ganz
viele werden ihr auch von freunden und
verwandten abgeholt wird vielen dank für
diese eindrücke
es raus geschafft zu haben aus dem krieg
ist das ein aber wohin dann auch
deutschland richtet sich darauf ein
seinen teil beizutragen und menschen
aufzunehmen brandenburg beispielsweise
tausende plätze stehen bereit allein in
eisenhüttenstadt sind es 800 frankfurt
oder sammelt spenden noch sind es nicht
viele die den weiten weg geschafft haben
aber das wird sich ändern
es sind die letzten kilometer in polen
nur noch ein stück dann kommt schon
brandenburg die autobahn hier eine der
direktesten verbindungen aus der ukraine
und tatsächlich auf einer tankstelle
treffen der marianna aus lemberg west
ukraine mehr als einen tag haben sie und
ihre freunde im auto für die knapp 900
kilometer gebraucht alle sind erschöpft
ich bin sehr gestresst es ist sehr
schwierig über alles zu reden über das
gefühl dass wir flüchten mussten sie
gehören zu den ersten die kommen
ansonsten ist dann der brandenburgischen
grenze noch überraschend wenig vom nur
gut 800 km entfernten krieg zu merken an
der stadtbrücke von polen nach frankfurt
oder normaler betrieb dennoch bereitet
frankfurts bürgermeister gerade seine
stadt darauf vor dass es jederzeit mehr
geflüchtete werden könnten nur wann
heißt niemand kennen die meisten
menschen kommen ja irgendwie aus
verschiedenen teilen des landes in der
ukraine die haben also erstmal einen
großen weg an die grenze müssen
wahrscheinlich auch erstmal sicheren weg
versuchen zu finden vorbei an
kriegshandlungen und am kampfgeschehen
dann die wartezeiten an der polnischen
grenze und polen ist ja auch sehr gut
vorbereitet die haben schon vor zwei
wochen angefangen ihre struktur
hochzufahren und viele ukrainer gehen
doch erst einmal nach polen denke ich
was den bürgermeister bewegt viele in
frankfurt engagieren sich schon jetzt
wollen die menschen in der ukraine
sandra schmidt und philipp hennig haben
heute spenden gepackt
also viele sachen die man sofort essen
kann die man dann wahr machen kann
natürlich besonders wichtig hühnersuppe
dann haben wir in zukunft brauchen wir
haben kissen mitgenommen wir haben
decken wir haben heute morgen erfahren
dass gesammelt wird und haben sind
aufgestanden und uns dann überlegt so
schränke auf wir müssen einfach mal
schauen was wir entbehren können
wir wollen hört uns engagieren zu wollen
helfen die spenden liefern die
frankfurter jetzt bei einer
studierendengruppe ab die gleich mehrere
hilfsprojekte gestartet hat regelmäßig
werden die studierenden nun an die
ukrainische grenze fahren und die
spenden abliefern meine motivation ist
meine familie die momentan in der
ukraine liegt
sie können sie haben dort absolut nichts
sie haben sie haben das haus verlassen
ohne gelte ohne klamotten
ohne adresse und deswegen habe ich
gedacht ich kann nur eine kleinigkeit
machen um dieser aktion hier
organisieren und wenigstens einen
anderen menschen in der ukraine oder in
polen helfen ähnliche private
hilfsprojekte laufen bereits in vielen
orten brandenburgs an
gleichzeitig sorgt das land für
unterbringungsmöglichkeiten bis zu
11.000 menschen aus der ukraine könnte
es aufnehmen in den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen wie hier in
eisenhüttenstadt sind viele zimmer
derzeit leer zur sicherheit wurden aber
auch noch zusätzliche feldbetten
aufgestellt
also der erstaufnahmeeinrichtung von
brandenburg haben wir nominale von einer
1000 plätze davon sind zu jeder zeit so
zwischen 3.200 3300 belegbar wir haben
aber jetzt schon
durch die ereignisse die tragischen der
ukraine also etwas aufgestockt um ein
paar hundert plätze und haben auch noch
einiges in reserve auch viele gemeinden
daten gespannt was auf sie zukommt die
kleinstadt google etwa im süden
brandenburgs direkt an der grenze zu
polen sie hält leere wohnungen vor die
noch von der letzten flüchtlingswelle im
herbst voll ausgestattet sind was den
bürgermeister aber besonders freut seit
ausbruch des krieges bekommt er immer
wieder hier angebote aus der bevölkerung
ja mal abgesehen von den e mails wenn
ich hier auf mein handy gucke über
whatsapp wurde über die sozialen medien
vielleicht zwei beispiele einer privaten
personen guten tag herr mago dies von
heute darf ich privat eine
flüchtlingsfamilie aus der ukraine zu
mir nach hause nehmen wir haben nicht
viel platz aber die leute haben kein
dach mehr über dem kopf und bauch
unterkunft wie kann man helfen die
solidarität mit der ukraine
sie ist spürbar in brandenburg zum
wochenbeginn werden steigende ankunft
zahlen vermutet doch wie viele kommen
werden und wie lange sie bleiben genau
kann das weiterhin niemand sagen
viele helfende hände wenn sie den
menschen in der ukraine helfen wollen
können sie das tun beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die iban
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 und
weil das immer schnell geht können sie
die infos auch nachlesen unter spenden
punkt zdf.de oder im zdf text in aller
ruhe nach schauen auf der seite
352 zivilisten sollen bisher ums leben
gekommen sein in der ukraine darunter 14
kinder so meldet kiew inwieweit das
stimmt lässt sich von hier nicht sagen
dass menschen sterben steht außer frage
selbst moskau hat inzwischen eingeräumt
dass soldaten gefallen sind
4300 sollen es sein niemand weiß es
genau
die bilder und meldungen der vergangenen
stunden fast nils monat zusammen
dunkle rauchschwaden füllen den himmel
nahe der hauptstadt auch an nunmehr
fünften tag der russischen invasion der
ukraine ein öl depot steht noch immer in
flammen offenbar infolge eines
russischen raketen angriffs auch in der
hauptstadt selbst soll es heute nacht
wieder heftige explosionen gegeben haben
der russische vormarsch aber soll ins
stocken geraten seien diese satelliten
bilder des us-unternehmens messer sollen
einen konvoi aus russischen
militärfahrzeugen nördlich von kiew
zeigen
bürgermeister teams richtet sich an
seine bürger
unsere verteidiger bereiten sich darauf
vor unserer hauptstadt zu beschützen
jeder in kiew sollte die nacht im bunker
verbringen der feind bombardiert weiter
unsere häuser und sich so viele
infrastruktur aber er erleidet auch
heftige verluste
nach ukrainischen angaben wurden bisher
4500 russische soldaten getötet
überprüfen lässt sich diese zahl nicht
dieses video wurde von der ukrainischen
armee veröffentlicht es soll einen
drohnenangriff auf einen russischen
raketenwerfer zeigen parallel läuft die
mobilmachung weiter immer mehr
reservisten bereiten sich auf den kampf
vor
wir verteidigen unser zuhause deswegen
werden diese einfachen jungs jetzt
eingezogen das sind große patrioten sie
wissen was zu tun ist und werden den
feind stoppen
reservisten in der nähe von kiew lern
rudimentäre erste hilfe den umgang mit
waffen und selbstverteidigung bevor sie
auf patrouillen geschickt werden für
jegliche unterstützung ist man hier
dankbar im angesicht der situation
jede kleinste unterstützung ist
hilfreich für uns ob waffen oder
ausrüstung ich möchte den menschen
danken sie haben sich versammelt um zu
helfen kontrollpunkte aufzustellen sie
haben ihre fahrzeuge und ihre zeit
geopfert sie lassen ihre kinder zu hause
zurück um hier erde in eimer zu führen
sie verstehen alles aber niemand hätte
erwartet dass dieses dumme arschloch bis
hierhin vordringt
putin selbst bezeichnet das verhalten
von spitzenvertretern führender nato
staaten als aggressiv
die sanktionen des westens illegal und
antwortet mit einer weiteren
eskalationsstufe
deshalb befehle ich dem
verteidigungsminister und dem
generalstabschef die nuklearen
abschreckungskräfte der russischen armee
in höchste kampfbereitschaft zu
versetzen
kurz darauf meldet sich der ukrainische
präsident selensky er stimmt
verhandlungen mit russland zu dessen
delegation wartete bereits in minsk
setzte ein ultimatum
doch die ukraine wollte nicht in belarus
verhandeln nun lenkt sie ein
die russische und die ukrainische
delegation werden sich an der grenze
treffen und zwar ohne vorbedingungen
allerdings ich verspreche mir von dem
treffen nicht viel schauen wir was sie
anzubieten haben
das ukrainische volk scheint
währenddessen geeint in seiner
entschlossenheit mit allen mitteln
widerstand zu leisten
ein ukrainischer ex-premierminister
erklärt per video wie molotow cocktails
gemacht werden
auf dem marktplatz von mehr pro wird
diese theorie bereits in die praxis
umgesetzt hier versammeln sich unzählige
menschen schaffen styropor herbei und
leere flaschen um die einfachen wurf
waffen massenweise herzustellen unsere
generation wir haben alle geschichten
gehört über unsere großväter die den
nazismus bekämpft haben wie märchen über
die man gelächelt hat aber jetzt sind
wir wie unsere großväter
anwohner in mario pohl versammeln sich
in einem sportstudio hier schlagen sie
lager auf suchen schutz ältere mütter
kinder säuglinge
die großen wandspiegel werden abgeklebt
im falle eines angriffs sollen sie nicht
zerspringen die aktuellen verhandlungen
mit russland sind für die menschen hier
ein mögliches licht am ende des tunnels
ein hoffnungsschimmer
ich sitze und bete dass diese
verhandlungen erfolgreich sind
dass das töten endlich aufhört und dass
es keinen krieg mehr gibt
die hoffnung ist groß wo die not am
größten ist bei den verhandlungen die
aktuelle an diesem tisch stattfinden
dürften geht es um den frieden in europa
fragen wir nach in moskau bei anna fest
wir haben es gehört eine delegation
trifft sich also über frieden zu
verhandeln
wie glaubhaft und wie ernsthaft wird das
von russland aus betrieben
schaut man sich an wie die russische
delegation zusammen gesetzt ist hat man
zweifel dass russland hier wirklich
einen echten dialog sucht an der
delegation spitze der russen steht im
dienste der ehemalige kulturminister
heute präsidentschafts assistent und man
hätte deutlich einflussreiche politiker
finden können die solche verhandlungen
führen dann ist natürlich der ort
bedenklich nahe der bella russischen
grenze und die gespräche mit organisiert
durch lukaschenko den belarussischen
präsident und erst gestern wurde von
bella russischen territorium zwei
raketen auf die ukraine abgefeuert und
insofern sind das keine guten
vorbedingungen dieses gesprächsangebot
das russische gibt es ja seit tag eins
des krieges aber es ist seit tag eins
des krieges immer an zwei bedingungen
geknüpft nämlich die komplette
demilitarisierung der ukraine und ein
abrücken der ukraine von einer
nato-mitgliedschaft und insofern kann
man hier nicht von einer offenen
gesprächsbereitschaft von russischer
seite aus gern wie wirkt denn diese
angriffskrieg auf das meinungsbild
innerhalb russlands der rubel stürzt ab
lesen wir die sanktionen aus weiten
teilen der welt treten in kraft zeigt
das wirkung
ja der den rubel absturz bzw die
sanktion zeigen wirkung der rubel ist um
42 prozent abgestürzt die russische
zentralbank hatte deswegen den leitzins
auf 20 prozent angehoben was man die
russische zentralbank hat gleichzeitig
immer klar gemacht es gibt genug geld
die russischen bürger müssen sich keine
sorgen machen das meinungsbild also von
denen menschen mit dem wir reden konnten
ist dann ein bisschen zwiegespalten die
einen sagen wir sind sowas gewohnt also
es ist natürlich keine gute situation
wir sind es aber gewohnt dass man so mit
uns umgeht und was sollen wir jetzt tun
die anderen sind wirklich besorgt dass
hat am wochenende schlangen an den
geldautomaten gegeben die menschen
kaufen vielerorts westliche technik
smartphones und tv setzt weil sie
befürchten dass es diese produkte eben
bald nicht mehr hier auf dem hiesigen
markt geben könnte danke allenfalls für
diese schilderung live aus moskau wir
ahnen aber wir wissen nicht wie wenig
ernst putin brüssel genommen hat was wir
aber wissen inzwischen ist wie
entschlossen größere reagiert schauen
wir dorthin denn es tut sich einiges ina
baltes fangen wir damit an dass
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten
lenski telefoniert hatte in der nacht
und eine meldung lässt hinhören die türe
der eu stünde für die ukraine offen wie
genau ist das zu verstehen
ja die beiden haben in der tat
telefoniert und ursula von der leyen hat
voluminöse lenski noch einmal gelobt für
seinen großen mut und seine stärke das
sei eine inspiration für uns alle hat
sie gesagt in einem interview später hat
sie dann nochmal gesagt dass die eu das
die ukraine auf lange sicht zur eu
gehören werde das darf man sich jetzt
aber nicht so vorstellen dass da jetzt
sehr schnell eu-beitrittsverhandlungen
mit diesem land aufgenommen werden es
gibt sehr sehr strenge kriterien für ein
land das der eu zu gehören will da muss
in sachen rechtsstaatlichkeit in sachen
fest demokratie und auch in sachen
wirtschaft müssen diese länder die
beitreten wollen auch zur eu gehören und
diese kriterien gilt es natürlich noch
vorab nachzuprüfen und selbst wenn man
jetzt zügig verhandlungen mit der
ukraine aufnehmen bisher haben solche
verhandlungen immer jahre gedauert und
ein sonder verhandlung wie selensky
jetzt vielleicht fordert hat es bisher
nicht gegeben das ist auch noch nie
gegeben hat brüssel will eine halbe
milliarde euro militärhilfe leisten wie
gesagt das gab es noch nie in der
geschichte der eu wie genau soll das
ablaufen
ja da haben in der tat gestern die
außenminister in einer video konferenz
zusammen gesessen oder auch hier gibt es
eine 1 arg strapaziertes wort aber so
ist es zeitenwende die eu hat noch nie
geld für waffen ausgegeben
jetzt sind es 450 millionen die die
ukraine bekommen soll für wirklich
tödliche waffen so heißt es hier also
panzerabwehrwaffen flugabwehrwaffen und
noch einmal weitere 50 millionen für
munition und ausrüstung
und das geld darf aber nicht aus dem eu
haushalt kommen weil damit dürfen keine
waffen finanziert werden es gibt einen
sogenannten europäischen friedens von
ironischer weise heißt der friedensfonds
aus dem dieses geld kommen soll und wie
genau das alles funktionieren soll da
will man heute bei den
verteidigungsministern die sich auch
wieder zusammensetzen darüber sprechen
und wahrscheinlich werden die waffen
dann über polen ins land gebracht danke
für diese informationen live aus brüssel
in arbeit ist
was ist mit den menschen die nicht ihr
land verlassen können oder wollen die
jede nach den bunkern in den
u-bahn-stationen oder zu hause durch
wachen in der angst zum ziel zu werden
für raketen mal wieder konrad und wenn
ihr bergerhoff haben deren stimmen
gesammelt
ich heiße juli wir befinden uns in hf
seit vier tagen sind wir mit booten
keller im schutzkeller und es geht uns
sehr schlecht wir werden nicht nur
militärobjekte beschlossen sondern auch
zivile bauten die wohnhäuser werden von
den geschossen getroffen die menschen
die überhaupt nichts mit den
kampfhandlungen zu tun haben müssen sich
verstecken wir können das haus nicht
verlassen
im keller nicht verlassen um frische
luft zu schnappen es fehlt uns an wasser
lebensmittel es ist so gut wie unmöglich
zu den einkaufszentren zu gelangen
[Musik]
ich zeige ihnen kurz wer mit mir
zusammen hier sitzt das sind alles
einwohner unseres hauses mit hunden mit
katzen und sogar eine ausländerin es
unter uns
die bedingungen hier sind nicht gut
unser morgen startet mit dem geräusch
von explosionen unsere tage vergehen mit
dem geräusch von schüssen die abende mit
dem geräusch von sirenen und die nächte
mit der angst getroffen zu werden wir
sind hier in schutzbunker um uns zu
verstecken und ums überleben zu kämpfen
ich wünsche mir nur dass schnell alles
wieder normal wird und der ukrainischen
armee viel kraft
wir hoffen dass unsere partner uns
helfen diesen idioten diesem fein putin
zu stoppen damit wir in der zukunft
friedlich und ruhig leben können
hier spricht 1 3 aus kiel wir haben hier
in meiner stadt bis montag eine
ausgangssperre
so habe ich zeit etwas über die lage
hier in der ukrainischen hauptstadt zu
erzählen
insgesamt ist die lage relativ ruhig
aber ich hatte eine schlaflose nacht in
meiner stadt kämpft nicht nur die armee
sondern auch zivilisten
die meisten einwohner kiew sind in
schutzräumen oder in ihren häusern
wir freuen uns auf den moment in dem
alles wieder in frieden endet
ich bin mit meiner familie zu verwandten
gezogen
aber wir sind dorthin gezogen weil sie
näher an der u bahn station und von dort
aus kann man schnell runter rennen um
sich zu verstecken wenn bombardiert wird
das haben wir in den ersten zwei tagen
schon getan wir haben circa fünf stunden
in der metro verbracht bevor wir wieder
in unserem
zurückgegangen sind
die boni angeschlossen wenn wir serien
oder schüsse hören rennen wir in den
hausflur dort sitzen wir an den wänden
und warten bis es aufhört
wir haben lebensmittel und wasser
gekauft für den fall der fälle
wir haben jetzt ausgangssperre und
wurden informiert dass es schwere kämpfe
rund um kiew geben könnte deshalb
verlassen wir unser zuhause gerade nicht
sind hier in der abteilung für
suchtkranke und wir gehen nicht raus nur
wenn ein mitarbeiter brot holt wir haben
vier laibe brot für 30 menschen bekommen
[Musik]
hier ist noch ein kleines zimmer was wir
ausgestattet haben 30 patienten sind
noch da ich bleibe bei ihnen meine
mitarbeiter habe ich zu ihren familien
geschickt drei tage halten wir durch das
wasser reicht für trinken und kochen bei
der menge von menschen die hier gerade
sind
was gerade in der ukraine geschieht
klingt den russischen staatsmedien ganz
anders nicht vom krieg ist da die rede
sondern von einer speziellen militär
operation von russische invasion zu
sprechen ist verboten werfen wir einen
blick darauf wie der kreml den krieg
darstellt und die menschen in russland
den krieg wahrnehmen
es war eine freie geheime allgemeine
wahl am 21 april 2009 10 bei der
wolodimir seelands geht mit 73 prozent
der stimmen zum präsidenten der ukraine
gewählt wurde russlands präsident putin
dagegen spricht von einer
volksfeindlichen runter die mithilfe
eines fingierten
wahlverfahrens die ukraine als geisel
genommen habe mit solchen
falschinformationen
deutet der kreml-chef die wahrheit um im
osten der ukraine seien es nicht
pro-russische separatisten die seit
jahren krieg führen sondern die ukraine
vor über dort einen genozid an millionen
von menschen solche behauptungen stützt
die russische seite auch auf bilder die
gefälscht und offensichtlich inszeniert
sind
hier sollen don jetzt ukrainische
saboteure ein ziviles auto angegriffen
haben bei dem angriff seien mehrere
zivilisten zu tode gekommen berichtet
ein reporter im fahrzeug sind
anscheinend die fast vollständig
verbrannten überreste mehrerer menschen
zu sehen ein leichnam allerdings weist
am schädel die glatten schnitte einer
knochensäge auf das typische bild nach
einer autopsie am verbrannten fahrzeug
fehlen die nummernschilder alles deutet
auf eine inszenierung hin wurden hier
bereits verstorbene menschen als opfer
eines ukrainischen anschlags präsentiert
eindeutig manipuliert ist dieses video
angeblich stirbt hier ein saboteur im
auftrag der ukraine der sich angeblich
selbst mit einer helmkamera bei seinem
sabotage angriff hielt im hintergrund
die geräusche eines schweren gefechts
vermutlich hat dieses gefecht nie
stattgefunden den experten haben in den
metadaten des videos nachgewiesen dass
die tonspur gefälscht ist der ton ist
kopiert worden von diesem youtube video
das eine finnische armee übung zeigt die
tonspuren beider videos sind absolut
identisch
auch dieser angebliche angriff der
ukraine auf stellungen der separatisten
ist nicht das was die russische seite
behauptet wieder soll ein ukraine mit
der eigenen hellen kamera gefilmt haben
bevor er angeblich getötet wurde das
kann nicht stimmen journalisten konnten
den ort der videoaufnahmen zweifelsfrei
bestimmen weit entfernt von den
behaupteten kampfhandlungen in den
russischen medien aber auch in sozialen
netzwerken weltweit verbreiten solche
bilder die russische version des
konflikts
[Applaus]
und so ist russlands krieg in putins
sprache kein krieg keine invasion
sondern eine spezialoperation um
russland unser volk zu verteidigen
wer glaubt oder behauptet in deutschland
gebe es keine meinungsfreiheit der tut
gut daran in diesen tagen nach russland
zu schauen es gibt dort mutige menschen
die gegen putins krieg und für ihre
meinung auf die straße gehen aber sie
werden mundtot gemacht mehr als 5000 von
ihnen wurden bereits festgenommen
wie anders ist hier in deutschland
zugeht zeigt roman leskovar auf der demo
gestern in berlin
die menschen strömen in scharen zur
kundgebung am mittag die polizei muss
zeitweilig die zugangsstraßen sperren
der u bahnhof am brandenburger tor wird
dichtgemacht es ist ein eindrückliches
zeichen dass an diesem sonntag
ausgesandt wird es können auch heute
noch zehntausende gegen krieg
protestieren wahnsinn das ist eine
unterstützung also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass so viele menschen auf die
straße gehen ich fühle mich ein bisschen
glücklich
die welt habe die augen aufgemacht das
ist ja auch total wichtig dass die
menschen in russland mitbekommen dass
das was total schief läuft so groß die
freude über die vielen teilnehmer so
tief sitzt der schock nach der
russischen invasion wut ist zu hören
mitgefühl bei vielen aber auch angst vor
einem russischen präsidenten der
womöglich schon weitere angriffs pläne
schmiedet
wenn der nato fall ausgerufen wird der
gegen seine verteidigung ist ist kein
stoppen mehr dann wird polen dann wird
dann wird es riesige flächen grant vor
82 jahren ist die hitler als letzte mal
ein gericht in der ukraine sbu die nach
halt so im grunde mächtig
frust statistische methoden zum ersten
mal erkenne ich in meinem leben der ich
nur mit frieden groß geworden bin das
plötzlich etwas am kippen ist das was
ich mir nie hätte vorstellen können dass
sich etwas grundlegendes verändert habe
betonen viele teilnehmer auch für die
demo kultur für frieden freiheit und
bewaffnung gleichermaßen auf die straße
zu gehen früher eher abwegig heute nicht
mehr dass die öffentlichkeit und
überhaupt die leute vielleicht mal mehr
darüber nachdenken wie wichtig ist es
dass man freiheit und demokratische
werte verteidigt und das dazu eben nicht
immer gehört dass man mit der
regenbogenfahne
durch die lande zieht sondern dass da
gegebenenfalls auch andere mittel dann
auch ergriffen werden unter den
demonstranten viele menschen aus der
ukraine aber auch aus russland tausend
kilometer entfernt führen sie krieg hier
stehen sie zusammen sie kommt aus drauf
warnt ich komme aus der ukraine
wir verstehen uns gut ist es überhaupt
kein problem zusammen zu sein bin ich
hier auch zu zeigen dass ich präsidenten
präsident meines landes nicht
unterstütze ich habe ihn nicht gewählt
der protestzug führte direkt an der
weiträumig abgesperrten russischen
botschaft vorbei welchen eindruck er
hinter den mauern hinterlassen hat wird
wohl ein geheimnis bleiben
heute ist rosenmontag dieser satz klingt
wie aus der zeit gefallen der
karnevalszug in köln war sowieso
abgesagt worden gegen korona aber als
der krieg ausbrach war klar auch das
fest dass gefeiert werden sollte kann so
nicht stattfinden und so macht köln
heute da weiter wo berlin gestern
aufhörte mit einem friedensappell und
für uns ist jan hofer vor ort was tut
sich da heute wer geht da alles auf die
straße an diesem tag
ja jetzt in diesem moment sind hier
zehntausende menschen auf der straße
demonstrieren und laufen die strecke
entlang wo eigentlich mal der
rosenmontags zu gelangen laufen sollten
mal wieder stoppt das ganze weil es wohl
deutlich mehr leute sind als die
veranstalter vermutet hatten man hat
auch hier die eigentlichen wagen die
eigentlich durch die stadt fahren
sollten ursprünglich an die strecke
gestellt wir können wir gerade einen
wagen zeigen der sich mit wladimir putin
beschäftigt erdacht allerdings lange vor
der russischen invasion in die ukraine
und so ist heute hier eben alles anders
und auch dieser wagen kommt ganz anders
als gedacht zur aufführung in köln mehr
köln und rosenmontag kennt der weiß die
menschen wollen feiern und eigentlich
wie gesagt sagt vor einer woche ja auch
noch so aus dass da ein bisschen was
geht was hören sie wie reagieren die
menschen
ja es ist wirklich ganz
unterschiedliches soll ja ein bunter ein
schriller ein lauter protest seien die
veranstalter haben gesagt kommt durch
auch verkleidet und dann ist es
tatsächlich so das gehört zur wahrheit
dazu dass eben viele die heute in köln
feiern wollen die kommen hier mit
bierchen hin demonstrieren etwas mit und
gehen danach in die kneipen die ja schon
die ganzen tag und auch heute in köln
sehr sehr voll sind andere wiederum und
auch da habe ich mit vielen gesprochen
den ist das ein riesen großes anliegen
heute hier ein starkes zeichen zu setzen
die sind heilfroh dass der
rosenmontagszug
abgesagt wurde na ja und das sind so ein
bisschen die beiden lager dieser welchen
protestkultur die wir hier gerade
erleben jan hofer danke für diese
schilderung live aus köln
nicht nur die deutsche bevölkerung zeigt
sich solidarisch auch die politik es ist
oft vorschnell von historischen
entscheidungen die rede hier aber trifft
es sicher zu eine zeitenwende wie es
heißt 100 milliarden euro werden
bereitgestellt für die bundeswehr als
preis der freiheit die verteidigung
unseres landes und unserer werte stehen
plötzlich ganz oben auf der agenda wie
schnell sich die zeiten ändern zeigt
ines trams
der krieg ist zurück in europa die armee
des russischen präsidenten fällt in der
ukraine ein er will grenzen verschieben
ist bereit bis zum äußersten zu gehen
wäre das zu verhindern gewesen durch
eine härtere politik des westens
deutschlands der ukrainische botschafter
in berlin sieht sein land als opfer
einer episch und politik
die ukraine fühlen sich als ein
opferlamm
und als quasi eine folge von von von
dieser beschwichtigungspolitik
deutschlands in den letzten jahren auch
in den letzten monaten vielleicht und
das macht meine landsleute das macht
auch nicht persönlich wütend
dialog hieß bislang der deutsche ansatz
man sah sich in der vermittlerrolle
wandel durch handel ein anderer
glaubenssatz putin ein partner kein
aggressor daran änderten auch seine
luftangriffe auf georgien nichts auch
nicht die annexion der krim heute nun
ist klar die deutsche russland politik
ist gescheitert putin hat die
verhandlungsbereitschaft von uns
ausgenutzt und hat gesehen dass dahinter
weder die absicht ist dies militärisch
zu unterfüttern noch die bereitschaft
diplomatie und härte eindeutig zu zeigen
die deutsche außenpolitik am
scheidepunkt ratlos eine härtere gangart
bislang hat man sie vermieden wollte
ungern in unpopuläre dinge wie militär
investieren und abschreckung wollte
niemanden verprellen nun muss man sich
neu aufstellen
das heißt nicht dass man wörter
vergessen soll aber es wird wesentlich
mehr darauf ankommen auch mit härte die
westlichen die demokratischen interessen
zu verteidigen
und ich glaube das müssen wir es wieder
neu lernen eine neue glaubwürdige
außenpolitik klar scheint
verteidigungsfähigkeit gehört dazu
ministerin lamprecht empfängt 350
zusätzliche soldaten in litauen es gilt
die ostflanke zu stärken wir stehen hier
wachsam und wehrhaft
ganz so ist es nicht die bundeswehr muss
sich strecken die aktuellen wünsche der
nato zu erfüllen drei zusätzliche
eurofighter nach rumänien eine korvette
eine kompanie in die slowakei noch immer
hat man die truppe nicht von
auslandseinsätzen umgestellt auf bündnis
und landesverteidigung das tut nun aber
nur wenn es um den sozusagen luftabwehr
gürtel geht wenn es aber gleichzeitig
und bodentruppen geht um unsere
eurofighter um unsere schiffe dann
wissen wir genau schauen wo haben wir
was verfügbar es ist nicht mehr alles
selbstverständlich da und diese
mangelverwaltung die macht uns natürlich
nahezu wahnsinnig tagtäglich nun
verspricht kanzler scholz der bundeswehr
100 milliarden euro extra doch es wird
dauern bis die in der truppe ihre
wirkung zeigen es gilt verkrustete
strukturen aufzubrechen
wir haben ganz viele große projekte die
jetzt an den start gehen können weil ich
eben auch die finanzielle rückendeckung
dann habe da ist vieles nicht
entschieden worden weil man darauf
gewartet hat das geht jetzt das sind
zwar lange abläufe aber es geht aber wir
müssen dann eben auch in der struktur
veränderungen vornehmen beispielsweise
beim vergaberecht der präsident von
litauen ist nach berlin gekommen für ein
gespräch mit dem kanzler stippvisite bei
demonstranten vor der russischen
botschaft
er befürchte putin wird auch nach
anderen osteuropäischen ländern greifen
er will unterstützung und beobachtet
eine änderung im deutschen denken
einige augen wurden geöffnet
noch vor zwei drei monaten war es
manchmal recht kompliziert über russland
zu reden so viele vorbehalte und
tradition doch jetzt beginnt jeder zu
verstehen was passiert
waffenlieferungen sind nun möglich genau
wie russlands ausschluss aus dem
internationalen
zahlungssystem eine zeitenwende in der
deutschen außenpolitik deutet sich an
putins brutalität ließ keine andere wahl
wie sich alles ändert die ersten
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine sind in
deutschland in freiburg beispielsweise
kamen inzwischen mehr als 150 heimkinder
muss der nähe von kiew in bussen an das
war eine lebensgefährliche flucht die
hinter ihnen liegt dorothea dörner war
bei der ankunft dabei
über 70 stunden fahrt liegt hinter ihnen
159 heimkinder mit ihren betreuern aus
der ukraine
sind in freiburg im breisgau angekommen
die kinder kommen aus einem heim in der
nähe von kiel mit vier bussen flüchteten
sie über polen nach deutschland über
2000 kilometer
die lange fahrt nicht ohne dramatische
zwischenfälle
in einer stadt rom nur das ist weiter
weiter westlich wurden wir gedacht haben
wir sind jetzt außer gefahr sind sie von
drohnen also beschossen worden die
coaching ist pokal ist die kinder sind
sehr erschrocken ukrainische polizisten
die die busse begleitet haben hätten die
kinder beschützt erzählt roman komiker
verletzt wurde dabei niemand der
freiburger oberbürgermeister martin horn
ist geschockt von den erzählungen
zehn stunden an der ukrainischen grenze
eine mobilmachung wo ein vater
aussteigen muss sein eigenes kind im bus
zurücklassen muss also das kann man sich
eigentlich westeuropäisch kann nicht
vorstellen denn männer im alter zwischen
18 und 60 jahren dürfen so zeit ukraine
nicht verlassen die bus verraten glück
und durften weiterfahren
mit der ersten gruppe mit ich persönlich
gesprochen habe waren dreijähriges kind
das war komplett eingesetzt und hat und
nur ein handtuch um gebunden weil sie
keine ersatzteile mehr hatten im bus die
ganzen materialien eine ganze kleider
kommt der sozusagen mit den ukrainischen
bussen nach gefallen weil wir in dresden
bus wechsel organisiert haben in der
turnhalle eines gymnasiums gibt es essen
und die kinder werden medizinisch
untersucht was in ihren köpfen vorgeht
das kann im moment niemand sagen
zitiert wir sind dann in wenigen stunden
nach dem kriegsbeginn sind die kinder um
zehn stunden zehn jahre gehalten
diese kinder sind in sicherheit sie
werden erstmal in
flüchtlingsunterkünften und in einer
jugendherberge untergebracht
[Musik]
fünf tage lang führt russland nun krieg
gegen die ukraine fünf tage den ganz
europa bereits viel verändert haben über
alle entwicklungen halten wir sie auf
dem laufenden in unserem live blog auf
zdf heute.de und in unserer app